it was terrifying we need to pray
no i jumped like 35 000 times and
whatever happens don't stop praying
oh no
get that everybody my name is curly we
are here in the mexico to watch
warner brothers new movie the nun and
then 17th century
ex-convent in a place called el di
sierto de los leones where are you at
nuns
okay which way oh this way it shares a
lot of its space with a lot of nature
so the green is everywhere the green is
growing on the buildings they have
green everywhere and if you know me you
know that that's my aesthetic it looks
like my apartment
i'm going to become a nun a long time
ago if i knew that's how they were
living i'm here to get scared i'm here
to watch a movie i'm here to see some
ghosts i'm here to see what's
up i feel very lucky that i get to watch
a scary movie
in a scary place and it's thundering
outside
the nine was actually super freaky the
effects in the movie are so beautiful
literally it was just so beautifully
done but now we're gonna go check out
this experience that everyone's talking
about i don't really scare that easily
so which makes me even more excited
i'm like up for the challenge
essentially like i'm like yeah let's do
this everyone says that it's super scary
so uh let's see these two nuns meet us
at the front door
they tell us that we have a mission to
save this convent
from this dark energy we walk through
the store
and there's all these crosses just
hanging everywhere and you're like
what then they start saying something
like no look in front of you there's
like letters that are missing
we go into this door there's a hallway
and down the hallway is like
this figure of a nun oh no let's get out
of here oh my god
this way quickly she's coming suddenly
somebody goes missing and i'm kind of
like
did we really just leave some dudes
saying
[Laughter]
it was kind of like a game meets a
treasure hunt
meets like a play that you're involved
in
there's music playing there's people
screaming and
then they're like let's go outside
follow me
over here it is
pitch black in there you open the door
inside the door there's like a little
necklace
well a big necklace i believe this is
what we've been seeking let's go quickly
do it sister let's get it
so we take it and uh we start running
quickly
you have like all these like monks
chasing you
oh my god yo
this is like where's the bb class you
have all these nuns chasing you
and dead are alive and none are among
chasing me it's just scary
it's crazy
the coffin opens up and it's that guy
that was missing
i'm like how where have you what
follow me come on come on guys i don't
know if i should follow you
we go into this room where there's a
like a huge
fan that's blowing all these things into
the air i put my hood on so fast i
didn't want any of that stuff in my hair
if you have curly hair you know exactly
what i'm talking about there's more
screaming more hollering to use this
necklace that we found a few seconds ago
to close the portal we pour it the
portal closes
you did it sister it was so much
fun yo that was dope thank you warner
brothers for sending this latino boy
from la to mexico city
to watch this movie go if you want to
get scared go if you like getting scared
make sure that you take a date with you
and then go home and sleep with the
lights on ask levi ten people to protect
you because
you don't need it after you watch this
movie go see the night in theater
september 7th